the jurogan experience i didn't even get
sober
for two years after that wow so
or a year after how long after the heart
attack do you start partying again
three it took about three months for me
to like spruce my goose up enough to get
nuts
and that is the turning point when i i
where i truly believe
that i turned into like a [ __ ]
full-blooded like addict
because then all of a sudden i had an
out
you know i had a safe out you know i had
the story
i had the love of all my friends we're
like maddie we're with you
you know so much beautiful support from
all of my my crew's deep
and i was just like so much good love
from my friends and then all of a sudden
i started hiding
going to different places different bars
different little
drug homes i like to call them you know
little travel houses yeah little places
little little critter critter little
homes is that a trap house
no no trap house where you dance trap
house
[ __ ] checks what happens in trap houses
you can say it the drunk business
happens the business happens
and then you go to the other house to
use it usually oh
okay you don't get high at the trap
house just business
no joe hey never get high on your own
supply
tank crack shot the biggie the um
you know i think that's when i really
was getting [ __ ] crazy
and that's when i started turning like
less fun and more of an addict yeah i
got very violent
really yeah like i got i got banned from
our own nightclub
i got banned from like you know i got
walked in on and i was trying to like
rob pretty much this drug dealer i was
like i swung on like i would be
blackout drunk trying to fight my
friends and like being like you can't
stop like because people would try to
stop me
they would like i would walk into a bar
and like because i'm in the hospitality
group
like you know i'm in the crew so it's
just imagine
imagine like being a comedian and
somebody gets almost like blacklisted
but we still love you
but you can't show up here um but we
love you you can do
your comedy like by yourself out in your
car but you can't come in here
right and i'm just like well i want to
still go into the bar
i go to the bar every day the bar is my
that's my safe place
you know i want i want to go into the
bar like let me in and everyone's like
you're not dying here
you're not dying at my [ __ ] bar so
then i had to start going to these like
deeper darker places and push myself and
and and before when i used to do drugs
i never had to say [ __ ] it in your head
you know when you're about to jump
and you gotta be like [ __ ] it let's go
you know so those moments when you
often have to be like you have to push
yourself i was doing that with drugs
where i'd be like i know now i know that
i could die
before my ego was like you'll never die
maddie
you're the [ __ ] man but now all of a
sudden my ego
is a little bit shook but my ego still
is like [ __ ] you you're gonna keep doing
this
and so i had to keep doing it and i had
to keep saying [ __ ] you
to myself so every time that i started
doing drugs
i would be like [ __ ] it let's go and
then that was the moment when i was just
like
that's when [ __ ] got dark and so there
was like a year of that
and then my last time i ever drank
the last time i ever did any like
[ __ ] anything
was uh you know nine years ago
the weekend of november whatever 12th
and my friend was visiting from
england a chef and we were doing a big
dinner
and i got so [ __ ] drunk
and i i brought i walked in friday
service mid-service
didn't even show up for work took this
chef out and
and was just like you know didn't tell
anybody i'm just like bringing my buddy
around town being a host
and i show up and all the partners were
sitting at one of the chef's tables so
there was like
in the big kitchen at parts in this
warehouse there was like three chef
tables so
the vips the homies all the people got
to sit in the chef tables
and all the partners were sitting there
and i walked in and they're like
what's up you don't have to show up for
work bro you get to do whatever you want
to do
kind of thing like what the [ __ ] and i
was just like
what the [ __ ] do you want and i was just
like and i was like what do you want
your restaurant's packed
this [ __ ] look at this i walked out
into the middle of the dining room and i
was like hey
everybody who the [ __ ] is having the
best time ever
and everyone's like and i looked at all
the partners i was like
[ __ ] you these are this is my crew this
is my [ __ ] world
that didn't go well
[Laughter]
ego i was such a psychopathic young
psycho well those two things booze and
coke i mean
i they are little pee-pee i got to make
it up somewhere you know like it's it's
it is it's it's so hard to to
to you know fill the void you know and i
just
i found that with that and then you know
the next day
one of my partners was like hey let's
meet for coffee
i want to fire you to your face and i
was just like okay yeah
fire me you can't like i was like what
are you gonna do with your restaurant
bro
what are you gonna do with all your
restaurants i'm the face of your company
i'm the guy
and i showed up and uh
he was like meet me here i'll pick you
up we're gonna go for a coffee i was
like okay
let's meet up and i knew that i could
manipulate and talk to him and
you know be like we're cool you know i
won't do it again
[ __ ] yeah yeah just manipulate
manipulate manipulate mine
and [ __ ] and uh
he drives me and it's like oh my god he
pulls up to like my homies house
who's like straight edge vegan warrior
oh boy and i'm just like oh
perfect and then like four of my dudes
come out
and i'm just like okay let's see what
you [ __ ] losers got to say
you know let's hear what all my best
friends got to say about me
how much you love me and how much you
care about me let's see what you [ __ ]
like losers got to say
you know like instantly going into like
hating these people that are trying to
like help me
and uh you know the veils that can come
when you sit down in front of your best
friends
your true your your your true inner
circle
the people you can't lie to the people
that you can't there's no facade there's
no media there's no nothing it's you
and your friends and i sat down and i
listened
for like four hours and um
you know and the next day one of the
guys there
goes to meetings and he's like we're
going to a meeting and so the next day i
walked into a meeting
and um you know the miracle happened
and i had a meeting yeah what what what
made you
hit the switch you go from is everybody
having a good [ __ ] time to
all right i'm done yeah because i think
the lying
within that four year four hour period
that transitional period
i that was my out i could stop lying
because i was lying
the lying is what really broke me it's
about whether
where i was going where i was going the
people i was hanging out with
lying to trish another thing i've been
with trish for
like 21 years you know she's
a [ __ ] saint she's a hard-bodied
italian irish woman she's [ __ ]
you know three home births she doesn't
[ __ ] around yikes
she's she's [ __ ] real damn birds bruh
i'll birth the child right now
jamie you got a baby in there let's go
i'll birth you
so the [ __ ] i was like why isn't
trisha here
and she's like she's out it's up to you
she's got nothing left to say
she's out it's up to you now and i was
like huh
i don't like that and even now like
you know like i feel i can trigger
that feeling of this is real
this is it this is this is a time where
i can stop this is a time where i can
i don't i can stop okay i accept you
know i accept
that i'm i i i have a a chance at not
ever
having to lie i have a chance i don't
have to do that again
you know catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience